Hi, everybody. Ira Glass here. So our staff is busy reporting out stories for next week's show and for other upcoming shows. And we had a rerun scheduled for this week, and we decided in this stressful time it might be nice to keep things light and funny. And so that's what this episode is.
大家好，我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们的团队正忙着为下周以及之后的节目采编故事。我们本周原本安排了一期重播，但在这个压力重重的时期，我们觉得保持轻松幽默或许会更好，所以本期节目就是这样。
And it has not one, but two of the most popular stories we have ever put on the air. The first version of this episode was broadcast over 20 years ago, back when we were distributed by Public Radio International and our episodes began with a little PRI audio logo, which-- I don't know-- I kind of miss.
这期节目不仅有一段，而是两段我们有史以来最受欢迎的故事。这期节目的最初版本是在20多年前播出的，那时我们还是由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行，我们的节目开头都有一个小的PRI音频标志，那个标志——我不知道为什么——我还挺怀念的。
From PRI, Public Radio International.
来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。
Public Radio.
公共广播。
Public--
公共——
Radio International.
国际广播。
--Radio International.
——国际广播。
One more time.
再来一次。
What could be more American than the person who sees something they've never done before, dreams they could do it, goes after that dream? Well, let's begin today with a woman who dreams of directing a play in the small town where she lives, a college town, somewhere below the Mason-Dixon line in the hills of Appalachia, a town which will remain, for our purposes today, unnamed.
还有什么比一个看到从未做过的事情、梦想自己能做到并去追逐那个梦想的人更具美国精神呢？好吧，让我们今天从一位梦想在自己居住的小镇执导一部戏的女性说起。那是一个大学城，位于梅森-迪克逊线以南的阿巴拉契亚山脉，为了我们今天的目的，这个城镇将保持匿名。
I don't think she had ever directed. And she claimed to have acted. And it was never really quite clear just what her credentials were. But she had managed to convince the local theater department of this college that she should direct a production of Peter Pan.
我不认为她有过执导经验，她也只是声称演过戏。她的资质到底如何，从来都不太清楚。但她成功说服了这所大学的当地戏剧系，让她来导演一部《彼得·潘》。
When he was in the 10th grade in 1973, Jack Hitt saw her production. And like everybody else in town, you heard about it for weeks beforehand.
杰克·希特在1973年上十年级时看了她的作品。就像镇上的其他人一样，你在几周前就听说了这件事。
Slowly, but surely, you began to hear sort of rumors about this production. For example, I know that they had spent a lot of money renting these flying apparatuses out of New York. And apparently there's like one company and a handful of these apparatuses. And so to get them was a major coup.
慢慢地，确实，你开始听到关于这部戏的各种传闻。比如，我知道他们花了很多钱从纽约租借了这些飞行装置。显然只有一家公司有少量的这种设备，所以能弄到它们是一项重大成就。
This is a story not just of a mediocre play or a terrible play. When it comes right down to it, it's not even a story about a play. This is a story about a fiasco and about what makes a fiasco. And one ingredient of many fiascos is that great, massive, heart-wrenching chaos and failure are more likely to occur when great ambition has come into play, when plans are big, expectations great, hopes at their highest.
这不是一个关于平庸之作或烂戏的故事。归根结底，这甚至不是一个关于戏剧的故事。这是一个关于惨败以及惨败是如何造成的故事。许多惨败的一个组成部分就是：当伟大的雄心介入、计划宏大、期望很高、希望达到顶峰时，巨大的、令人心碎的混乱和失败就更有可能发生。
And what you have to understand is that everybody in this sort of community understood that they were-- there was certainly a sort of air of everyone sort of reaching beyond their own grasp. Every actor was sort of in a role that was just a little too big for them. Every aspect of the set and the crew-- and rumors had sort of cooked around. There was this huge crew. There were lots of things being painted.
你需要明白的是，这个群体里的每个人都明白，他们确实在试图超越自己的能力范围。每个演员扮演的角色都稍微有点难以胜任。舞台和剧组的每一个方面——传闻四起。有一个庞大的团队，有很多东西在被粉刷。
See, but this, in fact, is one of the criteria for greatness, is that everyone is just about to reach just beyond their grasp, because that is when greatness can occur.
看，但这实际上是伟大的标准之一，就是每个人都准备好去触及自己能力之外的东西，因为那正是伟大可能发生的时候。
That's right. That's right. And maybe greatness could have occurred.
没错，没错。也许伟大本可以发生。
Well, today on our program, what happens when greatness does not occur? What happens, in fact, when fumble leads to error leads to mishap and before you know it you have left the realm of ordinary mistake and chaos, and you have entered into the more ethereal, specialized realm of fiasco? Today's show, "Fiascos-- A Philosophical Inquiry," perhaps the first ever, as far as we know, into what makes a fiasco, what takes our ordinary lives that extra distance into fiasco.
好吧，今天我们的节目要讨论的是，当伟大没有发生时会怎样？事实上，当失误导致错误、错误导致事故，在你意识到之前，你已经离开了普通错误和混乱的领域，进入了惨败这一更空灵、更专业的领域。今天的节目《惨败——一次哲学探究》，据我们所知，这可能是史上首次探究是什么造就了惨败，又是什么将我们的日常生活推向了惨败的深渊。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. There is much, much more to learn about fiascos in this hour. Stay with us.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在这个小时里，还有更多关于惨败的内容值得了解。请留下来。
We begin our show with this true fable of Peter Pan in Act One, "Opening Night."
我们的节目以第一幕“首演之夜”中关于《彼得·潘》的真实寓言开始。
Opening night comes and, you know, well, almost everybody in the area in the 10-mile radius of this theater knows somebody in this production, so the place is pretty much packed. And I don't know if you remember the opening moment of Peter Pan, but it's the three little kids sleeping in their bed. And Peter Pan comes flying in the window. And in this particular production, there's a big bed with all the three kids in it. And off to the left, I remember, is a big, huge wardrobe, and there's a large window there and a little bureau.
首演之夜到了，在这个剧院方圆10英里内几乎每个人都认识制作中的某个人，所以现场几乎座无虚席。我不知道你是否还记得《彼得·潘》开场的瞬间，三个小孩子睡在床上。彼得·潘从窗户飞进来。在这个特定的制作中，有一张大床，三个孩子都在上面。我记得左边是一个巨大的衣柜，还有一扇大窗户和一个小抽屉柜。
And Peter Pan comes in and has a little speech where he says, anybody can fly. Why, with just a little magic dust, one can fly. And Peter Pan sort of sprinkles this magic dust in the air. And sure enough, the kids sort of suddenly just lurch into the air.
彼得·潘进来后有一段独白，他说任何人都能飞。只要撒一点魔法粉末，人就能飞。彼得·潘在空中撒了一些魔法粉末。果然，孩子们突然就摇摇晃晃地飞到了空中。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
And it becomes clear right away that the people that they've hired to run these flying apparatuses really aren't quite clear on how they actually work. So instead of the kids sort of sailing gracefully to and fro, they sort of hang in the air like puppets, just sort of dangling there and sort of getting jerked up an inch or two or back and forth.
很快就很明显，他们雇来操作这些飞行装置的人根本不清楚它们到底是怎么工作的。所以孩子们没有优雅地飞来飞去，而是像木偶一样挂在空中，悬在那里，被猛地向上拉一两英寸，或者来回晃动。
And then sometimes they're just stationary?
有时候他们只是静止不动？
Yeah, just hanging there like a spider. And then several of them start to sort of circumscribe these circles in the air, where it's clear that the people running the machines have just sort of set them off on these oval courses that spiral farther and farther out.
是的，就像蜘蛛一样挂在那里。然后其中几个人开始在空中画圆圈，很明显操作机器的人只是把他们设置在椭圆形的轨道上，然后越转越远。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And if you were sitting in the audience, there was clearly a sense of fear on the faces of these people.
如果你坐在观众席上，可以清楚地从这些人脸上看到恐惧。
Of the actors?
演员的脸？
The actors. The actors, actually, you could sense their lack of confidence, shall we say--
演员。演员们，你可以感觉到他们缺乏信心，我们这么说吧——
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
--in the people running the machines in the back. So they--
——对后台操作机器的人缺乏信心。所以他们——
Wait, wait. And the audience reaction to this point is just-- are they laughing?
等等，等等。观众到目前的反应是——他们在笑吗？
No one is laughing. One of the great things about audiences, especially in a live theater production, is that they're very forgiving. They want the show to work. And so everyone is sort of gripping their chair a little tightly. We feel for them. They're up there-- they're embarrassing themselves for us.
没有人笑。现场戏剧表演中观众的一大优点是他们非常宽容。他们希望演出顺利。所以每个人都紧紧地抓着椅子。我们为他们感到难过。他们在上面——他们为了我们而在出丑。
We identify with them. We become them.
我们与他们感同身受。我们变成了他们。
And so the audience, I think, was very forgiving and very understanding of this moment. But there was one moment in this first opening scene that kind of put the audience on notice. And that's when, as the kids are sort of jerking up and down, and swinging back and forth, and sort of going around in these ovals, at one point the littlest one, the little boy, is sort of being flung around a little too--
所以我认为观众非常宽容，非常理解这一刻。但开场的第一幕中确实有一个时刻让观众提心吊胆。那就是当孩子们一边摇晃一边来回摆动，在椭圆轨道上转圈时，那个最小的小男孩被甩得太厉害了——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--a little too hard.
——太用力了。
Well, he has the least mass to resist, whatever the machinery is doing to him.
好吧，他的质量最小，最难抵抗机器对他做的事情。
Right.
没错。
OK, so and?
好吧，然后呢？
And so he's flying around in a circle. And the audience sort of sees this coming. And there's a real sense of pain, and gripping of the chair, and white-knuckledness as the kid suddenly does just an enormous splat into the wardrobe. And it's clear that he's hurt.
所以他在空中转圈。观众预见到了这一点。当那个孩子突然狠狠地撞在衣柜上时，大家感到一种真实的痛苦，紧紧抓着椅子，指关节都发白了。很明显他受伤了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he comes off of it sort of a little dazed. And then, of course, he's jerked up in the air a little bit and often a little too high so that he's suddenly sort of in the workings. He's sort of left the stage itself. He's now up there with the lights. Then all of a sudden, he just sort of--
他从上面下来时有点晕头转向。然后，当然，他被向上猛地一拉，通常拉得太高，以至于突然进入了灯光和复杂的机械中。他已经离开了舞台。他现在就在灯光那边。然后突然之间，他只是——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Suddenly, he would just plummet back down to the stage and be caught up just before he hit the floor. [LAUGHS] It was hard to watch because, as you can tell, it's an incredibly funny moment. But like I say, the audience was still in this very forgiving mode.
突然，他会猛地跌回舞台，在撞到地板前被接住。[笑声] 这很难看，因为如你所见，这是一个极其滑稽的时刻。但正如我所说，观众仍然处于这种非常宽容的状态。
And no one said a word. We just all sat there sort of holding our breath. And there's that weird tension of being in the audience thinking, oh, oh my goodness. They have gotten off to a very bad start. Oh, this is not good. And we feel for them.
没有人说一句话。我们只是屏住呼吸坐在那里。有一种坐在观众席里的奇怪紧张感，心想，哦，天哪。他们开局真的很糟糕。哦，这不太好。我们为他们感到难过。
May I just interrupt for just a moment--
能让我打断一下吗——
Yeah.
可以。
--just to say-- because after all, we are not just joined here together on the radio, you and I, today to laugh at the foibles of the unfortunate. No, no. We're here to enumerate the qualities of a fiasco. At this point, we are not yet in the territory of fiasco.
——只是说——因为毕竟，我们今天聚在这里，不仅是为了嘲笑不幸者的失误。不，不。我们是为了列举惨败的特质。在这一点上，我们还未进入惨败的范畴。
No, no. Because, like I say, audiences are forgiving. And one or two mistakes, even big ones like this, they're going to let that ride.
不，不。因为正如我所说，观众是宽容的。一两次错误，即使像这样的大错误，他们也会放过。
Yes, they are.
是的，他们会。
We did. We did. We were very good.
我们做到了。我们做到了。我们表现得很好。
So we are not yet at fiasco. We are at a sort of normal level of mishap.
所以我们还没有到惨败的程度。我们正处于某种正常水平的失误。
Right. What happens immediately after this, they disappear to Never Never Land. And if you remember, the stage goes dark. And then when the lights come up, there's Captain Hook. And he's giving his first opening soliloquy about how evil he is, and what a menace he is, and how he harms people, and hates children. And it's all that good stuff.
没错。紧接着这一幕发生后，他们消失去了“梦幻岛”。如果你还记得，舞台变黑了。当灯光亮起时，胡克船长出现了。他正在进行他的开场独白，讲述他有多邪恶，他是一个多么大的威胁，他如何伤害他人，厌恶孩子。都是那些经典台词。
And so Captain Hook is out there. He looks great. He's got one one of those big, old, fat hats, and this great hook, and these wild looking boots and everything.
所以胡克船长在那儿。他看起来很棒。他戴着那些巨大、陈旧、肥大的帽子，还有那个很棒的钩子，穿着狂野的靴子等等。
And people are feeling more confident. Something's happening.
人们感到更有信心了。事情正在好转。
It's a good sign. It's a good sign. And he's in charge. This guy, he's got a bad mustache, and he is certainly evil.
这是个好兆头。这是个好兆头。他在掌控局势。这家伙，他留着糟糕的胡子，而且他确实很邪恶。
Yes.
是的。
And the audience is totally in his pocket. He's speaking away, and gesturing wildly, and going on and on about how bad he is. And then at a certain point, as he gestures, his hook and the entire black casing up to his elbow flings off of his hand and flies into the audience, and punches an old lady in the gut.
观众完全被他吸引了。他正在滔滔不绝地演说，动作狂野，不停地讲述他有多坏。然后在某个时刻，当他做出动作时，他的钩子和一直到手肘的黑色外壳从手上飞了出去，飞向观众席，重重地打在一个老妇人的肚子上。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He is bad.
他确实很坏。
He's very bad. He had the worst ad lib I've ever heard. I mean, what do you say at that point? Because, of course, his hand is now nakedly exposed to the audience.
他真的很坏。那是他即兴发挥的最糟糕的一次。我的意思是，在那种情况下你还能说什么？因为，当然，他的手现在赤裸裸地暴露在观众面前。
A tough moment for any actor.
对任何演员来说都是一个艰难的时刻。
Very, very hard.
非常、非常艰难。
If the premise of your character is that you have a hook, your name is Captain Hook, literally all that's going to happen for the rest of the show is people are going to refer to you by that hook. Your entire motivation as a character is the fact that you're--
如果你的角色前提是你有一个钩子，你的名字叫胡克船长，从字面上看，演出剩余时间里人们只会提到那个钩子。你作为角色的全部动机就是因为你——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--is that your arm was eaten off by an alligator and that you have to have a--
——是因为你的手臂被鳄鱼吃掉了，你必须有一个——
The entire plot--
整个情节——
--and you have a hook.
——你有一个钩子。
--stems from that fact.
——都是基于那个事实。
And now suddenly, you have no hook.
现在突然，你没有钩子了。
In fact, you have five fingers on a hand.
事实上，你手上有五根手指。
As if a miracle by the Lord.
仿佛是上帝显灵。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Captain Hook said, you know, they just don't make those hooks like they used to. That was actually the ad lib. I will never forget it.
胡克船长说，你知道，现在的钩子质量真的不如从前了。那其实是他的即兴发挥。我永远不会忘记这一点。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Then the lights come up, and we are in Never Never Land.
然后灯光亮起，我们到了梦幻岛。
In act two?
在第二幕？
Yeah, this is act two. And Captain Hook might have stood in front of the set, but you didn't really see it because he spoke from shadow. And now the lights come up, and it's supposed to be a very dramatic moment.
是的，这是第二幕。胡克船长可能站在布景前，但你看不真切，因为他是在阴影中说话的。现在灯光亮起，这本来应该是非常戏剧性的一刻。
The rumors of all this crew, and the painting, and everything that was going on, and all this construction all worked towards this one moment. Because when the lights came up, here was Never Never Land, this sort of psychedelic set. There were papier-maché mushrooms everywhere of different sizes. It was absolutely wonderful and surreal.
所有关于剧组、绘画、以及所有正在进行的建设传闻，都是为了这一刻。因为当灯光亮起时，这就是梦幻岛，一种迷幻的布景。到处都是不同尺寸的纸糊蘑菇。它绝对是奇妙而超现实的。
Wow.
哇。
And there's nobody there. And then from the upper rafters of stage right, suddenly the kids and Peter Pan appear.
但那里一个人也没有。然后从舞台右侧上方的椽子里，孩子们和彼得·潘突然出现了。
Flying?
飞着的？
Flying. They're flying.
飞着的。他们在飞。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
And their landing-- their landing occurs rather rapidly, at an angle of about 45 degrees to the stage. They come down basically like-- I don't know-- lead sinkers on a line and crash to the floor, and then are sort of just dragged across the floor like mops, and wipe out all of the mushrooms.
他们的着陆——他们的着陆非常迅速，以大约45度的角度撞向舞台。他们基本就像——我不知道——线上的铅坠一样降落，重重地摔在地板上，然后像拖把一样被拖过地板，把所有的蘑菇都扫平了。
And so now have we arrived at a turning point in our fiasco?
所以现在我们到达惨败的转折点了吗？
Yeah. Yeah, it's clear now that the audience is giving way. Something has been lost, some sense of decorum, that little bit of forgiveness that the audience has for the actors.
是的。是的，现在很明显观众已经放弃了。某种东西丢失了，某种礼仪感，观众对演员的那一点宽容。
And empathy.
还有共鸣。
And empathy. It's beginning to dissipate. Well, there was a split in the audience. Sort of the younger people who were the least forgiving, they started to go first, OK? So the high school students, couple of college students maybe, they started to laugh out loud. And I'll be honest, Ira, I might have been one of those first people to laugh. I was in the 10th grade. It was hard to not laugh at this.
还有共鸣。它开始消散。好吧，观众出现了分歧。那些最不宽容的年轻人开始先笑了，对吧？所以高中生，也许还有几个大学生，开始大声笑出来。说实话，艾拉，我可能就是第一批笑出来的人之一。我当时上十年级。很难不对此笑出声。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
But then whatever restraint that the audience had, it just evaporated at this point because there were a number of things that happened in quick succession that just made it impossible to hold any sense of decorum.
但后来观众所剩的任何克制都在这一点上蒸发了，因为接下来发生了一连串的事情，让人无法保持任何礼仪感。
Which are?
比如？
For example, Tinker Bell appears for the first time around this moment. And Tinker Bell is essentially a light bulb on an extension cord.
例如，小叮当（Tinker Bell）第一次出现在这个时刻左右。小叮当本质上就是一个挂在延长线上的灯泡。
What?
什么？
Yeah. And this was the director's idea of being raw, being very modern. Tinker Bell was just going to be this literal light bulb dangling from an extension cord.
是的。这是导演认为的“原始”、“非常现代”的想法。小叮当只是一个挂在延长线上的普通灯泡。
Whereas in other productions, what they do is that someone will shine a light.
而在其他制作中，他们通常做的是让人照一道光。
Shine a light, or they'll just--
照一道光，或者他们只是——
A beam of focused light, and then that pinprick of light is supposed to be Tinker Bell.
一束聚焦的光，那个光点被认为是小叮当。
That's right, or something like that or nothing at all. And people just address the invisible sprite. Well, that did not happen in this case. This bulb comes just dangling down and sort of hangs around.
没错，或者类似的东西，甚至什么都没有。人们只是对着看不见的精灵说话。好吧，这次的情况并非如此。那个灯泡就那样垂下来，悬在那儿。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
This naked light bulb--
这个裸露的灯泡——
A bare light bulb?
一个光秃秃的灯泡？
--just hangs around, and people are talking to it.
——就在那儿挂着，人们还在跟它说话。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I think Tinker Bell-- Tinker Bell must have had an appearance in the first act, but it was somewhere in here that people just started laughing at this.
我想小叮当一定在第一幕出现过，但就是在这一处，人们开始对此大笑。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Then another thing that happened was later on in this scene, if you remember, Wendy gets trapped on an island. And she spots a kite that's flying by, and she's supposed to grab it and attach it to her back and fly off.
然后发生的另一件事是在这一幕的后面，如果你还记得的话，温蒂被困在岛上。她发现一只风筝飞过，她本该抓住它并把它系在背上飞走。
Well, of course, the kite is attached to the flying apparatus line. And it gets closer and closer to her. She's standing on this little papier-maché hill. But the flying apparatus people can't quite get it close enough to her to reach. So she has to step out into the water that she's just told us is filled with crocodiles to grab it. She finally gets the kite. And when she yanks on it, it pops off the flying apparatus. And the hook goes zinging up into the lights and catches.
嗯，当然，风筝系在飞行装置的绳子上。它离她越来越近。她站在那个纸糊的小山上。但飞行装置操作人员无法让它靠近到她能触及的范围。所以她不得不走到她说充满鳄鱼的水里去抓它。她终于拿到了风筝。当她用力拉时，它从飞行装置上弹开了。那个钩子呼啸着飞进灯光里并卡住了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So now there is this big loop of wire hanging in front of the stage, and there's Wendy holding the kite. And she ad libbed as best she could, as I remember. She sort of said, on second thought, maybe I can swim. And with that, she walked off the stage, sort of motioning her arms like you would do the swim, the dance in 1965.
所以现在舞台前悬着一个大线圈，温蒂手里拿着风筝。据我记得，她尽力即兴发挥了。她大概说，再想想，也许我会游泳。说完，她走下舞台，手臂做着像1965年那样游泳的舞蹈动作。
So she does that. At this point, I mean, the actors are just falling apart. They are so frightened of the audience. There are just belly laughs rolling up to the stage from the audience. People are howling with laughter at every mistake.
所以她做了。在这一点上，我的意思是，演员们简直要崩溃了。他们非常害怕观众。从观众席传来滚滚的哄堂大笑。人们对每一个错误都笑得前仰后合。
And now any small mistake just takes on these-- any instigation for laughter is just enough for this audience. And now the old people have given it up. Everyone has quit being nice. Now there's just this kind of frightening roar that comes from the audience every time there's a mistake.
现在任何小的错误都变得——任何引发笑声的借口对观众来说都足够了。现在老年观众也放弃了。每个人都不再装好人了。现在每当发生错误时，观众席都会发出一阵可怕的咆哮。
Well, what happened? At some point, the audience turned and realized, oh, wait. I realize what's going on here. This is a fiasco.
那么发生了什么？在某个时刻，观众转变了念头，意识到，哦，等等。我意识到发生了什么。这是一场惨败。
Yeah, this is a fiasco. And what's really interesting about a fiasco is that once it starts to tumble down, the audience wants to push it further along.
是的，这是一场惨败。关于惨败，真正有趣的是，一旦它开始坍塌，观众就想把它推得更远。
Oh, they get hungry for more fiasco.
哦，他们渴望更多的惨败。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
If the play proceeded perfectly, they would be disappointed.
如果戏演得很完美，他们会感到失望。
Oh, it would have been a grave disappointment had there not been just one more mistake after another, one more embarrassment after another. Now the reason they're there is to chronicle these embarrassments. This is why I have remembered this play for 25 years. Towards act three, the director had decided that she wanted to break down the fourth wall. This was cutting edge theater, as far as she was concerned.
哦，如果不是一个又一个的错误，一次又一次的尴尬，那将是极大的失望。现在他们在那里的原因就是为了记录这些尴尬。这就是我25年来一直记住这部戏的原因。到了第三幕，导演决定她要打破“第四面墙”。就她而言，这是尖端戏剧。
Before you do this, I just want to explain-- when we say breaking down the fourth wall, what we mean is the wall between the actors and the audience. Usually it's impermeable, but then there came a point in the late '60s, early '70s where a lot of theaters, basically the actors would come out into the audience.
在你继续之前，我想解释一下——当我们说打破第四面墙时，是指演员和观众之间的墙。通常它是不可逾越的，但在60年代末、70年代初，很多剧院里，演员基本上会走到观众中间。
That's right, and interact with the audience, and break down that wall, so the idea being that you would get more in touch with the dramatic sense and the reality of what was happening. Anyway, so in this particular scene, what was going to happen was that the Indians were going to throw rope ladders down from the balcony, and climb down these rope ladders into the audience, and move among the audience, and frighten us. Anyway, I knew about this scene because my friend David, who I went to high school with, was in it. So when David was climbing over the top of this balcony to climb down the rope, he lost his footing and fell to the floor from the balcony, a distance of about 15 to 20 feet.
没错，与观众互动，打破那面墙，其理念是你将更深入地接触到戏剧感和正在发生的现实。总之，在这一特定场景中，本来打算让印第安人从阳台上扔下绳梯，顺着绳梯爬进观众席，在观众中穿行，吓唬我们。总之，我知道这一幕，因为和我一起上高中的朋友大卫就在里面。所以当大卫爬过阳台顶端去爬绳子时，他没站稳，从阳台摔到了地板上，距离大约15到20英尺。
Oh my god.
我的天。
A good fall.
重重的一摔。
That's horrible.
太可怕了。
Yeah. And he landed on both of his feet and sprained both of his ankles, and, of course, curled into a fetal position and began to cry. He was really, really hurt.
是的。他双脚着地，扭伤了双脚脚踝，当然，蜷缩成胎儿姿势开始哭。他真的很疼，真的很疼。
Now, to appreciate the horrible moment I'm now describing, also understand that it's a Friday night, we are in a college town, and there is a volunteer fire and ambulance department. And in order to summon the rescuers from wherever they are, an alarm is sounded that can be heard for five miles. That alarm is located right over this theater.
现在，要体会我现在描述的这个可怕时刻，还要明白这是一个周五的晚上，我们在一个大学城，有志愿消防和救护部门。为了从他们所在的地方召唤救援人员，会响起一个可以在五英里外听到的警报。那个警报器就位于这个剧院正上方。
So the alarm goes off, OK? This is an air raid siren. It is so loud, you can put your fingers in your ear and it's still hurting your ears. We're right under it. It can be heard for five miles.
所以警报响了，好吗？这是一个空袭警报。声音大到你捂住耳朵还是会感到耳痛。我们就住在它下面。它可以在五英里外听到。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And then, of course, three minutes later, busting through the door of the theater, are these 15 firemen, who are in boots, hats. They got hoses. They don't know what it is. All they know is that they've been sent out on a call. And to sort of add to the chaos, the director, of course, has sort of flogged the actors that the show must go on.
然后，当然，三分钟后，15名消防员破门而入，他们穿着靴子，戴着帽子。他们拿着软管。他们不知道发生了什么。他们只知道是被叫过来的。为了增加混乱，导演当然一直在鞭策演员“演出必须继续”。
No matter what.
无论发生什么。
So no matter what. So while all of this is happening and several people are attending to David, and other people have just now decided that since the firemen are here he's going to be fine, they can start laughing. And now the audience has just completely lost control. People are standing up in their seats and shouting for more. They want blood. I mean, at this point, people are actually injured in the production, and they want more. Somehow that's how this entire play ended.
所以无论发生什么。因此，当这一切正在发生，几个人正在照顾大卫，其他人现在认为既然消防员来了他会没事的，他们可以开始笑了。现在观众已经完全失去了控制。人们站起来，在座位上大喊要求更多。他们想要血。我的意思是，在这一点上，制作过程中确实有人受伤，而他们想要更多。不知何故，这就是整部戏结束的方式。
What's interesting about this as a fiasco-- I feel like the thing it makes me understand about fiascos is that the fiasco itself is an altered state. That is, all the normal rules are off. You have left the normal rules of how the audience is going to interact with the actors.
作为惨败，这很有趣——我觉得这让我明白的关于惨败的事情是，惨败本身是一种改变的状态。也就是说，所有的正常规则都不适用了。你已经离开了观众如何与演员互动的正常规则。
Right. I've never seen a production like this, and I've never seen an audience collapse like this.
没错。我从未见过这样的作品，也从未见过观众这样崩溃。
See, but I wonder, when you think about what people go to theater for, like what kind of release people want, I mean, people want an experience that will take them out of themselves. We all want an experience that will take us out of ourselves and into another place and another reality. And it sounds like this production, even though it was a fiasco, in fact, because it was a fiasco, was more successful at that than any conventional play could be.
看，但我很奇怪，当你思考人们去剧院是为了什么，比如人们想要什么样的释放，我的意思是，人们想要一种能让他们超脱自我的体验。我们都想要一种能让我们超脱自我，进入另一个地方和另一种现实的体验。听起来这部作品，尽管它是一场惨败，实际上正是因为它是惨败，在这方面比任何传统戏剧都更成功。
Well, see, I would disagree with you. See, I think the old theater critics, the ancients, would say that the reason you go to the theater and to see a great production is to be-- I think the word they used to use is "transported," the idea being that you would be lifted away from your animal nature and into these higher, more spiritual realms or get in touch with these greater tragic emotions. Of course, what happened here was the exact opposite. We get transported directly in touch with our animal being.
好吧，看，我不同意你的观点。看，我认为那些老派戏剧评论家，那些古人，会说你去剧院看一部伟大的作品的原因是为了——我想他们过去使用的词是“升华”（transported），理念是你将被从动物性中提升出来，进入这些更高、更精神的领域，或者接触到这些伟大的悲剧情感。当然，这里发生的是完全相反的事情。我们被直接传送去接触我们的动物本能。
Our baser selves.
我们更低级的自我。
Right. But that's almost as rare, if not more so, than a great production.
没错。但这几乎和一部伟大的作品一样罕见，甚至更罕见。
Jack Hitt, he's the co-host of a great Peabody Award-winning podcast about race and history called Uncivil, which, if you are looking for something to listen to during this national home lockdown or on your commute to your essential job, I really recommend that. Jack says, by the way, that people ask him about this Peter Pan story still, all these years later. In the year since we first ran this, we got a letter from one of the actors in that production that Jack saw, a guy who played a pirate, who told us Jack, quote, "did not go far enough. He only covered the opening night. The subsequent performances were no better."
杰克·希特，他是那档获得皮博迪奖的伟大种族与历史播客《Uncivil》的联合主持人。如果你在这场全国性的居家隔离期间，或者在通勤上班的路上想听点什么，我真心推荐这个。顺便说一句，杰克说，这么多年过去了，人们仍然会问他这个《彼得·潘》的故事。在我们首次播出这期节目后的几年里，我们收到了一封来自杰克看的那部剧中演员的信，那个演海盗的家伙告诉我们：“杰克，你说的还不够。他只讲了开幕之夜。随后的演出也好不到哪去。”
[MUSIC - "I WON'T GROW UP" BY RICKIE LEE JONES]
[音乐 - 里基·李·琼斯演唱的《I Won't Grow Up》]
(SINGING) I won't grow up. I don't wanna go to school just to learn to be a puppet and recite a silly rule. If growing up means it would be beneath my dignity to climb a tree, I won't grow up, won't grow up, won't grow up, not me.
（演唱）我不会长大。我不想去学校，只是为了学会成为一个木偶并背诵愚蠢的规则。如果长大意味着为了爬树而丢掉尊严，那我不会长大，不会长大，不会长大，不是我。
Act Two, "Squirrel Cop." Well, human error is often at the heart of a fiasco, but what happens when you combine human error with, what we'll call in this case, animal error? We have this story of a police officer in a suburban community on the East Coast.
第二幕，“松鼠警察”。嗯，人为错误通常是惨败的核心，但当你把人为错误与我们姑且称之为“动物错误”的东西结合起来时会发生什么？我们有这样一个故事，关于东海岸郊区社区的一名警官。
There was nothing, nothing going on-- Saturday night in this village, really quiet, super cold. And this call came over for unknown animal in a house. And it was on my post. It was about five minutes away. So myself and another car were assigned the call, and we show up there.
当时什么事也没有——周六晚上的村子，非常安静，超级冷。然后接到了一个关于屋子里有不明动物的电话。就在我的管辖区。大约五分钟路程。所以我和另一辆车被指派去处理这个电话，我们赶到了那里。
And luckily for me, it was another guy who was pretty new. So we walk up to the door with all our stuff on-- the nylon coat, the vest, the belt, the whole nine yards. And the door opens. And the guy who is behind the door, he's about 30. I was 23 at the time.
幸运的是，另一个家伙是个新手。所以我们全副武装走向门口——尼龙外套、背心、腰带，整套行头。门开了。站在门后的那个人大约30岁。我当时23岁。
He's about 30. He looks like a broker or a lawyer, just really well put together, nice guy, wearing glasses. He's wearing these silk pajamas with a monogram. Got my attention.
他大约30岁。他看起来像个经纪人或律师，穿戴整齐，人很好，戴着眼镜。他穿着印有首字母的丝绸睡衣。吸引了我的注意。
Wow.
哇。
And he's going, listen, really sorry to bother you. Normally I'd handle this sort of stuff on my own, but my wife really insisted that I call. And so we ask him what the problem is.
他说，听着，真的很抱歉打扰你们。通常这种事我会自己处理，但我妻子坚持要我打电话。所以我们问他问题出在哪儿。
He says, well, we were having kind of a romantic evening down in the living room, and we heard this scratching upstairs. So I ran upstairs to see what it was. And it turns out it's coming from the attic. There's something up there, and it's just running around, knocking a few small things over. I can't tell what it is. It could be a squirrel, a raccoon. I really don't know.
他说，嗯，我们在楼下客厅度过一个浪漫的夜晚，然后听到楼上传来抓挠声。所以我跑上楼去看是什么。结果发现是从阁楼传来的。上面有东西，它一直在跑来跑去，撞倒了一些小东西。我看不出是什么。可能是只松鼠，浣熊。我真的不知道。
So the other cop that I was with said, well, we really don't handle that. It's not so much a police function. But we do have numbers of these private contractors who will come in, and they'll put a humane trap down, and they'll remove the animal for you. And it's really not such a big deal, but it's really not our thing.
所以我旁边的另一个警察说，好吧，我们真的不处理这个。这不完全是警察的职责。但我们有一些私人承包商的电话，他们会来放一个诱捕笼，帮你把动物移走。这真的不是什么大事，但真的不归我们管。
So right as he was in the middle of saying that and getting us off the hook, the guy swings the door back. And there's his wife, who was just beautiful. She was beautiful. She was probably about 26 or 27, but just really beautiful, like perfect skin, long blonde hair, great teeth, brilliant blue eyes, a really nice smile, just beautiful and friendly. If she had said, eat this broken glass, I just would have said, OK, broken glass it is. That's fine.
就在他这么说让我们脱身的时候，那个男人把门又打开了。他的妻子站在那里，她简直太漂亮了。她很美。她可能大约26或27岁，但真的很美，皮肤完美，长长的金发，漂亮的牙齿，闪亮的蓝眼睛，甜美的笑容，既漂亮又友好。如果她说，吃掉这些碎玻璃，我只会说，好吧，吃碎玻璃。没问题。
But she seemed really nice, so I was going to be like Galahad. So I just threw my arm back into this guy's chest, into my partner's chest. I said, Mark, we can handle this.
但她看起来真的很棒，所以我打算当加拉哈德（骑士）。所以我猛地把手臂挡在那个家伙的胸前，在我搭档的胸前。我说，马克，我们能处理这个。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
It'll be OK. And she was just, you know, thank you so much. And she was really sweet. And I was struck dead.
没事的。她只是，你知道，非常感谢。她真的很甜。我被迷住了。
So we walk inside. And she goes, I'm going to throw a pot of coffee on. And we go upstairs. We follow the man of the house upstairs. And we're underneath one of those trap doors that goes into the attic with a staircase that folds out.
所以我们走进屋里。她说，我去煮壶咖啡。然后我们上楼。我们跟着男主人上楼。我们在那个通往阁楼的活板门下面，那里有一个折叠出来的楼梯。
And we do hear an animal upstairs scratching away, just scuttling around the floor. And there's definitely something up there, and it's making pretty good speed up going from one end of the roof to the other. So I reached up, and I took the trapdoor down. We unfolded the ladder. And I have this big, heavy flashlight, like your cop flashlight-- 4D cells, the metal case, the whole thing.
我们确实听到楼上有动物在抓挠，就在地板上跑来跑去。上面肯定有东西，它在屋顶这一端跑到那一端，速度相当快。所以我伸手把活板门拉了下来。我们展开了梯子。我带着那把大而沉重的手电筒，就像警察用的那种——4节D电池，金属外壳，整套装备。
I shine it up through the hole in there, and it's pretty black. I can see the rafters, but really nothing else around there. And I start up the ladder.
我把它透过那个洞向上照，上面很黑。我能看到椽子，但周围真的什么也看不到。我开始爬梯子。
Now the guy who owned the house is standing almost directly underneath me, just to the side of the ladder, looking straight up at me. And my partner's at the base of the ladder, right behind me. So just before I stuck my head through this black hole, I just paused. I crunched my body up underneath 'cause I'm realizing, gee, I don't know where this thing is. The second we pull down the trap door, all noise upstairs just ceased.
现在屋主就站在我正下方，就在梯子旁边，抬头直视我。我搭档在我身后，在梯子底部。所以就在我把头伸进这个黑洞之前，我停住了。我缩着身子蹲在下面，因为我意识到，天哪，我不知道这东西在哪儿。当我们拉下活板门的那一秒，楼上所有的声音都停止了。
So I was kind of nervous. And I was like, well, I look like an idiot just crouched up here on the top of the ladder. So I took the flashlight, and I just popped my head up, turned the light on again. And about six inches from the front of my face was this squirrel at eye level with me, kind of reared back on its legs. And I swear, from where I was standing, it looked like Godzilla.
所以我有点紧张。我觉得我蹲在梯子顶上看起来像个白痴。所以我拿着手电筒，再次把头探进去，打开灯。离我的脸大约6英寸处，就是那只松鼠，和我平视，后腿站立。我发誓，从我站的角度看，它看起来就像哥斯拉。
It just scared the heck out of me. I thought, it's a squirrel. It's going to be hiding somewhere. It's going to be terrified of me. It was six inches away from me.
它真的把我吓坏了。我想，这只是一只松鼠。它应该躲在某个地方。它应该会怕我。离我只有6英寸远。
And it really startled me, so I kind of went, ah, and jumped back. And the flashlight slips out of my hands. It's heavy. And it falls directly onto the nose of the guy who's looking straight up at me. And I don't think it broke it, but it did some damage. And his nose-- his hands went up to his face. Blood just started pouring out between his hands.
它真的吓到了我，所以我“啊”了一声，向后跳。手电筒从我手中滑落。它很沉。它直接掉在了抬头看我的那个男人的鼻子上。我不认为断了，但造成了一些伤害。他的鼻子——他的手捂住脸。血开始从他双手之间喷涌而出。
This is the homeowner?
这是屋主？
This is the homeowner. I lose my balance and fall backwards directly onto my partner. And I pancake him.
这是屋主。我失去了平衡，向后倒，直接压在我的搭档身上。我像煎饼一样压扁了他。
We're both on our backs. He's on his back. I'm on his stomach on my back, scuttling around like a beetle trying to get up in this really narrow hallway. It's a mess. The squirrel, while we're floundering around in the hallway, jumps down the stairs-- boink, boink, boink-- lands on me, and takes off down the stairs.
我们俩都仰面朝天。他在仰面躺着，我背对着压在他的肚子上，像甲虫一样在狭窄的走廊里乱爬，试图站起来。简直是一团糟。松鼠在我们俩在走廊里挣扎时，跳下楼梯——咚，咚，咚——落在我身上，然后跑下楼去了。
How undignified.
多么有失尊严啊。
It was terrible. It was terrible.
太糟糕了。太糟糕了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
So we're wondering, gee, where is the squirrel? And right at that second, the woman who lived there, you hear her scream. So my partner goes, well, we found the squirrel. It's wherever she is.
所以我们想，天哪，松鼠在哪儿？就在那一秒，住在那里的那个女人发出了尖叫。所以我搭档说，好了，我们找到松鼠了。它就在她所在的地方。
Yeah.
是的。
So we go running downstairs. And the squirrel had come into the living room, where they had been having their romantic evening. They had a fire going. They had pillows arranged around one corner of the couch next to the fire. And they had champagne flutes out-- nice house, really nice. I mean, it just smelled brand new-- new carpeting, new rugs, new paint. They hadn't been there for that long.
所以我们跑下楼。松鼠跑进了他们度过浪漫夜晚的客厅。他们生着火。他们在火炉旁边的沙发一角摆放着枕头。他们还拿出了香槟杯——很好的房子，真的很好。我的意思是，闻起来简直像新的一样——新地毯，新垫子，新油漆。他们搬进来没多久。
So the squirrel, when it bolted down the staircase, took off into the living room and ran underneath a couch for cover. So we run downstairs. This guy is bleeding all over the place, on his carpets. His wife looks and says, what have you done to my husband?
所以松鼠从楼梯跑下来时，冲进客厅，躲到了沙发底下。我们跑下楼。这家伙的地毯上到处都是血。他的妻子看着说，你们对我丈夫做了什么？
I start going, oh, it was an accident. And I just stop in mid-sentence. What's the point? We've only been there about two minutes.
我开始说，哦，那是意外。然后我在半句中停住了。有什么意义呢？我们才在那儿待了大约两分钟。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
So the squirrel is underneath the couch. And my partner is going, let's get out of here. This is just-- it's not going well. So I'm not beaten yet. I always have another idea.
所以松鼠在沙发底下。我搭档说，我们走吧。这简直——情况不太妙。但我还没认输。我总有另一个主意。
So the squirrel is under this couch, which is in the middle of the room. So I have this bright idea. Why don't we move the furniture away from one of the corners, and we'll put the couch in the corner, and the squirrel will probably move along with the couch because it's the only cover available to it. And once we get into the corner, we'll only have two open sides of the couch to worry about. So we did that.
所以松鼠在那个沙发底下，沙发在房间中间。所以我有一个绝妙的主意。为什么我们不把家具从一个角落移开，我们把沙发放进角落里，松鼠可能会随沙发一起移动，因为那是它唯一可以利用的遮盖物。一旦我们进了角落，我们就只需要担心沙发的两个开放面了。所以我们照做了。
That is so tactical.
太有战术了。
Yes. Yeah, I was very proud of myself at that instant, but, you know. I asked her for a box, and she says, sure, we've got boxes. We just moved in. We have nothing but boxes.
是的。是的，那一刻我为自己感到非常自豪，但是，你知道。我向她要一个盒子，她说，当然，我们有盒子。我们刚搬进来。我们除了盒子什么都没有。
She runs out to the garage, and she comes back with a box. And the box is long enough, and it fits across the entire short side of the couch where the armrest would be. So I start sweeping underneath the couch with my nightstick, trying to move the squirrel toward the box, figuring we'll capture it and just get rid of it, and we'll be out of here, and there'll be no more mayhem.
她跑向车库，带回来一个盒子。盒子足够长，正好横在沙发扶手所在的那一短边。所以我开始用警棍在沙发下横扫，试图把松鼠赶向盒子，想着我们把它捕获然后把它弄走，我们就可以离开，就不会再有混乱了。
So it's actually working very well, and the squirrel's moving down along. You can hear it. It's chittering. And I'm trying not to hurt it.
所以其实进行得很好，松鼠正沿着下面移动。你能听到它。它在吱吱叫。我尽量不去伤它。
I'm nervous about the thing. It might bite me. I don't want to hurt it, really. It's just an animal.
我对这东西感到紧张。它可能会咬我。我真的不想伤它。它只是一只动物。
So I'm moving it along, and everything's going very well. And then with about eight inches to go I took one more swipe, and the thing just bolted out from underneath the couch. It was lined with tassels. I couldn't really see under the couch. It bolted out from underneath the couch and ran directly into the fireplace, which is about three feet away. The fireplace was directly ahead of it. And it ran into the fire--
所以把它赶着走，一切都进行得非常顺利。然后还有大约8英寸时，我又扫了一下，那东西直接从沙发底下窜了出来。它边上是一圈流苏。我在沙发下真的看不清楚。它从沙发底下一窜而出，直接跑向大约三英尺外的壁炉。壁炉就在它正前方。它跑进火里——
Oh, my.
哦，天哪。
--and caught on fire, and ran directly back out and directly back under the couch.
——着了火，然后又直接跑出来，直接跑回沙发底下。
Is it on fire?
它着火了吗？
It was on fire, yeah, the tail, the bushy fur, the whole bit. I mean, it wasn't flaming or anything, but it was smoking, and there was a little bit of fire coming off the tail. So it runs back under the couch. And the couch catches on fire in seconds, I mean, in seconds. It must have had dust under there or something else, but it caught on fire immediately.
是的，着火了，尾巴，毛茸茸的毛发，整个部位。我的意思是，它没有燃烧得很猛烈，但它在冒烟，尾巴上冒出一点火花。所以它跑回沙发底下。沙发瞬间着火了，我的意思是，瞬间。它下面可能有灰尘或其他东西，但它立即着火了。
And my partner and I just don't even talk.
我搭档和我甚至不说话。
We just grab the couch, heave it upside down, and now there's plenty of oxygen now for the fire to really get going. And it starts up, and we're patting it out. And it's sort of getting away from us. So we grab the only thing that's really available, and those are these really nice silk pillows. And we have one in each hand, both of us, and we're just windmilling away at this fire on the couch. And we put it out, but it's smoking terribly.
我们直接抓住沙发，把它掀翻，现在火有充足的氧气燃烧得更旺了。火势开始蔓延，我们正在拍打灭火。火有点失控。所以我们抓起真正能用上的唯一东西，那就是那些非常漂亮的丝绸枕头。我们俩一人手里拿一个，对着沙发上的火疯狂拍打。我们把它扑灭了，但烟味非常可怕。
It was a disaster. The couch is upside down. The bottom of it is burnt. The house is filling with smoke from the couch.
简直是一场灾难。沙发翻倒了。底部烧焦了。屋子里充满了从沙发散发出的烟雾。
The squirrel, when it went under the couch, in its death throes, just latched onto the bottom of the couch. It's like this smoking piece of gristle underneath the couch, latched on there with its claws. And we're pounding, smearing it all over the place.
松鼠在跑到沙发下时，在濒死挣扎中，直接抓住了沙发底部。就像一块烧焦的碎肉粘在沙发底下，爪子紧紧抓在那里。我们正在拍打，把它抹得到处都是。
The smoke alarms are firing away. The guy's standing with handkerchiefs and paper towels up around his nose, which is still bleeding. His pajamas are a mess. They're covered with blood, the front of them.
烟雾报警器响个不停。那家伙站在那里，用手帕和纸巾捂住鼻子，鼻子还在流血。他的睡衣一团糟。到处都是血，前面全是。
And we finally get the fire out. And we're both completely red, sweating because we're dressed for like zero-degree weather, and it's hot there by the fire. We're mortified. The house is full of smoke.
我们终于把火扑灭了。我们俩完全通红，浑身是汗，因为我们穿着足以抵御零度天气的衣服，而火炉旁很热。我们窘迫极了。屋子里满是烟。
The wife just looks around and just starts to cry. She goes, what have you done? What have you done to my house? You could see her just clicking things off on her fingers-- OK, the dead squirrel, ruined pillows, need a new couch. The walls are covered with soot. The fire alarm's going off. My husband's disfigured.
妻子看着四周，开始哭起来。她说，你们做了什么？你们对我家做了什么？你能看到她在心里盘算着——哦，死了的松鼠，毁了的枕头，需要新沙发。墙壁覆盖着煤灰。火警响个不停。我丈夫毁容了。
And then she really just lost it. And he was just looking at us and shaking his head like he couldn't believe that these two idiots showed up and did this to his house over nothing, really. And he just goes, you really haven't done anything wrong. I can't point to any one thing that you did that I have a reason to get angry about. You really haven't done anything wrong. I mean, we did call you, but I just-- I can't thank you for this.
然后她真的彻底崩溃了。他只是看着我们，摇着头，仿佛不敢相信这两个白痴跑来因为一点小事把他的房子搞成这样。他只是说，你们其实没做错什么。我指不出你们做的任何一件事是我有理由生气的。你们真的没做错什么。我的意思是，确实是我们给你们打的电话，但我只是——我无法因此感谢你们。
They call for a squirrel. They end up with like $3,000, $4,000 worth of damage and a broken nose. And this is all within about five minutes.
他们为了松鼠打电话。最后造成了大约3000到4000美元的损失，还有一个断了的鼻子。这全都在大约五分钟内发生的。
Could that have happened to you now, 13 years later?
13年后的今天，同样的事情还会发生在你身上吗？
There's always a new mistake to be made. I don't think I would make that particular mistake. I mean, you make plenty of mistakes. You make plenty of mistakes. That's just part of that job. You just try not to make the same one twice.
总有新的错误可以犯。我不认为我会再犯那个特定的错误。我的意思是，你会犯很多错误。犯很多错误是工作的一部分。你只是尽量不犯同样的错误两次。
But there's such variety that you're going to make hundreds. You're going to make thousands of mistakes. You're going to make thousands of mistakes until you really get a handle on what you're doing. And with police work, they afford you plenty of space to make mistakes. But there's things that just either they aren't your responsibility-- if you get involved in things that aren't your responsibility, or that you're really not equipped to handle, or that you don't have a specific plan, a plan that's thought through to a conclusion, you probably should re-evaluate what you're doing.
但错误种类繁多，你会犯成百上千次。你会犯成千上万次错误，直到你真正掌握自己在做什么。而在警察工作中，他们给你留有足够的空间去犯错。但有些事情要么不是你的责任——如果你卷入那些不是你的责任，或者你真的没有能力处理，或者你没有具体计划、没有深思熟虑到结论的事情中，你可能需要重新评估自己在做什么。
Now that you mention that, yeah, that's right. You walk into the house thinking, OK, we'll get the squirrel. Like, where are you going to get the squirrel? What was the best case scenario?
既然你提到了，是的，没错。你走进那间房子心想，好，我们把松鼠弄出来。就像，你要去哪里弄出那只松鼠？最好的情况是什么？
That's a great question. I guess I was thinking that I would go up there in the attic and find this cowering squirrel, and somehow lure it into some kind of a trap, and then walk out with it and be like a hero. But as it turned out, the squirrel-- it was a Pyrrhic victory for the squirrel, but the squirrel definitely won. The squirrel really kicked our ass.
那是个好问题。我想我当时认为我会爬上阁楼找到那只畏缩的松鼠，然后以某种方式把它引诱进某种陷阱，然后带着它走出来，就像英雄一样。但结果证明，那只松鼠——对松鼠来说这是一场惨胜，但松鼠肯定赢了。松鼠真的把我们打败了。
[LAUGHS] That is not what you want to be saying at the end of the day.
[笑声] 那可不是你想在一天结束时说的话。
No, no. I mean, it took me a long time to even tell people about it. I was so new. I didn't want anyone to know what a bonehead I was when I first came onto the job.
不，不。我的意思是，我花了很长时间才敢跟别人说这件事。我当时太新了。我不想让任何人知道我刚参加工作时是个傻瓜。
Our interviewee, who asked not to be named on the radio, had been on the force for 18 years when he spoke with me.
我们的受访者要求不在广播中提及姓名，他在接受我采访时已经在警队工作了18年。
[MUSIC - "FOX SQUIRREL" BY MUDDY WATERS]
[音乐 - 泥水佬演唱的《Fox Squirrel》]
(SINGING) My baby, she got ways like a fox squirrel swinging up in a tree. I know my woman, she got ways like a fox squirrel swinging up in a tree. Well, little darling, [INAUDIBLE]. She kept hopping all over me.
（演唱）我的宝贝，她像树上的狐松鼠一样。我知道我的女人，她像树上的狐松鼠一样。好吧，小甜心。[听不清]。她在我身上跳来跳去。
Coming up, what it's like to be invited to a big charity event that you then ruin. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，被邀请参加一个大型慈善活动却把它毁了是什么感觉。一会儿再说，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, fiasco. This is our own inquiry into the nature of what makes a fiasco. When you have left the world of mishaps, stumble human error, and you enter into the much more rarefied realm of fiasco, we have arrived at Act Three of our program-- Act Three, "Tragedy Minus Comedy Equals Time," specifically a long, long time between laughs.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们节目的每周，当然，我们会选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的各种故事。今天的节目，惨败。这是我们自己对是什么造就了惨败的本质的探究。当你离开了失误、碰撞、人为错误的领域，进入了更稀缺的惨败领域时，我们到达了节目的第三幕——第三幕，“悲剧减去喜剧等于时间”，具体来说，是在笑声之间漫长、漫长的时间。
So Mike Birbiglia is a comedian. He's been on our show lots of times. And years ago, years ago, he told this story about this one gig that he did relatively early in his career. He says it was the worst show he's ever done in his life.
迈克·比比利亚是一位喜剧演员。他上过我们的节目很多次。几年前，多年前，他讲了这个故事，关于他职业生涯早期做的一个演出。他说这是他一生中最糟糕的演出。
It happened this year. I was asked to perform at a charity golf tournament in New Jersey. So I woke up for this charity golf event. And I realized recently that I'm not a good adult yet. I think if you're a good adult, you plan your outfit according to what will occur when you leave the house. But I don't have that part of my brain. I'm just like, one outfit forever!
发生在今年。我被邀请去新泽西州的一个慈善高尔夫球赛表演。所以我为了这个慈善高尔夫活动醒来。我最近意识到我还没成为一个好成年人。我认为如果你是个好成年人，你会根据出门后会发生的事情来规划你的着装。但我没有大脑的那部分。我只是像，一套衣服永流传！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So when I played golf, I brought my brother, Joe. And Joe's kind of like a bad entourage member. He's never like, you the man, Mike. He's always like, I don't know what Dad would think about this, and do you think they have any more shrimp-- that kind of thing. But we showed up to play golf, and they paired us up with these two other people. It was a celebrity tournament, and people were like, who do you think our celebrity's going to be?
所以当我打高尔夫时，我带上了我的兄弟乔。乔就像个糟糕的随行人员。他从不像是，你是最棒的，迈克。他总是像是，不知道爸爸会怎么想这个，你觉得他们还有虾吗——那一类的事。但我们去打高尔夫了，他们把我们和另外两个人配对。这是一个明星锦标赛，人们像是，你觉得我们的明星会是谁？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And Joe and I were like, yeah, who do you think our celebrity is going to be? And then I'm like, oh, no. I think it might be me. And then I'm apologizing to these people. I'm like, I'm really sorry I'm your celebrity. If you think this is disappointing for you, you can't imagine how I feel.
乔和我像是，是啊，你觉得我们的明星会是谁？然后我像是，哦，不。我觉得可能是我。然后我一直在向这些人道歉。我像是，真的很抱歉我是你们的明星。如果你们觉得这让你们失望，你们无法想象我感觉如何。
So I'm apologizing the whole day. And then at the end of the day, sure enough, my pants are all wrinkled, and I have to perform at this semi-formal banquet. And I'm like, what about one outfit forever? I thought that was a good plan.
所以我一整天都在道歉。然后到了一天结束时，果然，我的裤子全皱了，而我必须在一个半正式的宴会上表演。我像是，什么“一套衣服永流传”？我以为那是个好计划。
And so here's what I do. As damage control, I go to the locker room to iron my own pants. And yeah, it's a pretty good plan. And I find an iron, but I couldn't find a board. So I take off my pants. I'm just ironing them on a bench in the locker room in my underwear, which is a dead giveaway that these are my only pants.
所以这就是我做的。为了挽回损失，我去更衣室熨我自己的裤子。是的，这是个挺好的计划。我找到一个熨斗，但没找到熨衣板。所以我脱掉裤子。我只穿着内衣在更衣室的凳子上熨裤子，这简直是明示这双裤子是我唯一的裤子。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So I'm ironing my pants. And I put them on. And I go up to the event. And this is where the trouble really begins. It's important for me, before I tell you this part of the story, to remind you that you're on my side.
所以我熨好裤子。我走上舞台。这就是麻烦真正开始的地方。在我讲这部分故事之前，提醒你站在我这一边很重要。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I say to the woman in charge-- I go, what's the format of the show? And she goes, well, there's two speakers, and then you, and then a raffle. And I was like, well, that's exciting because I've never opened for a raffle. I'm trying to stay optimistic. And I'm sitting in the back of the room with my brother, Joe. And the first speaker comes on the stage, and he's an 11-year-old boy who survived leukemia.
我对负责人说——我问，演出形式是什么？她说，嗯，有两位演讲者，然后是你，然后是抽奖。我像是，那很令人兴奋，因为我从未为抽奖做过开场。我试图保持乐观。我和兄弟乔坐在房间后面。第一位演讲者走上舞台，他是一个11岁的白血病幸存者。
[AUDIENCE EXCLAIMING]
[观众惊呼]
I know.
我知道。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He's not funny at all.
他一点也不好笑。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He focuses primarily on the leukemia, and everyone is crying. Literally everyone is crying. I'm even crying in the back of the room for two reasons-- one, the kid, and two, for me because I have to perform comedy. And it gets worse because Joe leans over, and he goes, this ain't looking so good, Mike.
他主要关注白血病，每个人都在哭。真的每个人都在哭。我甚至在房间后面也在哭，原因有两个——第一，那个孩子，第二，为我自己，因为我必须表演喜剧。而且情况更糟，因为乔靠过来，他说，这看起来不太妙，迈克。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I said, I concur.
我说，我同意。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The second speaker was Hall of Fame quarterback Phil Simms. And yeah.
第二位演讲者是名人堂四分卫菲尔·西姆斯。是的。
Whoo!
呜呼！
He's got one fan here.
他这里有一个粉丝。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But he's a broadcaster. And he gives an amazing, inspiring speech. And he even sprinkles in a few jokes about golf. They were similar to jokes I had thought of about golf that day. It was like watching the last drops of my joke canteen drip out onto a desert of cancer.
但他是一名播音员。他发表了精彩、鼓舞人心的演讲。他甚至穿插了几个关于高尔夫的笑话。它们和我那天想到的关于高尔夫的笑话很相似。就像看着我笑话壶里的最后几滴水滴落在癌症的沙漠上。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He gets a standing ovation, which he should have. Clearly the show is over. Surely there can't be anyone more famous than Hall of Fame quarterback Phil Simms. But wait, there was. It was Mike Birbiglia, who had no business being at this event.
他赢得了起立鼓掌，这是他应得的。显然演出已经结束了。肯定不会有比名人堂四分卫菲尔·西姆斯更出名的人了。但等等，还真有。那就是迈克·比比利亚，他根本没资格参加这个活动。
I know there are some entertainers who might have risen to the challenge, and I would love to be one of those entertainers, but I am not. As a matter of fact, I have a habit in my life of making awkward situations even more awkward. I've said this before, but a few years ago I was moving a new bed into my apartment. And this woman who lived in the building opened the front door for me with her key. And she goes, I'm not worried because a rapist wouldn't have a bed like that.
我知道有些艺人可能已经迎接挑战了，我很乐意成为其中之一，但我不是。事实上，我生活中有一个习惯，就是让尴尬的情况变得更尴尬。我以前说过，但几年前我正在搬一张新床到公寓。住在楼里的那个女人用她的钥匙帮我开了前门。她说，我不担心，因为强奸犯不会有那样的床。
That's how she started the conversation. Now, what I should have said was nothing. What I did say was, you'd be surprised.
她是这样开始谈话的。现在，我本该说的是什么都不说。我实际说的是，你会很惊讶的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
There's nothing you can say after that. You're just like, see you around the building, that kind of thing. I've thought about this a lot, and I think there's something wrong with my brain, where I don't have an on-deck circle for ideas. It's just batter up.
在那之后你什么也说不了。你只是像，回头见之类的。我思考了很多，我认为我的大脑出了点问题，我没有备选想法的循环圈。直接就是轮到击球了。
And a lot of the ideas are bad. And they're at the plate going, I don't know about this one, Mike. And I just turn into this drunk Little League dad. I'm like, you go take some cuts, son.
而且很多想法都很糟糕。它们在击球区像是，我不确定这个，迈克。而我只是变成了那个喝醉的小联盟棒球爸爸。我像是，你去挥几杆吧，儿子。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
As a comedian, when people laugh, it's very exciting. It's a very neat thing. And when they don't, it feels like you're performing jazz because they're kind of bobbing their head and looking to the side. And sometimes that's OK. I'm like, I like jazz.
作为一名喜剧演员，当人们笑时，非常令人兴奋。那是一件很棒的事情。当他们不笑时，感觉就像你在表演爵士乐，因为他们有点在点头，看向旁边。有时那没关系。我像是，我喜欢爵士乐。
But then I get worried because I'm like, sometimes jazz sucks. What if I'm the Kenny G of comedy? What if I think I sound like this, like-- [JAZZ SOUNDS]
但我开始担心，因为我像是，有时爵士乐很烂。如果我是喜剧界的肯尼·基（Kenny G）怎么办？如果我觉得我的声音是这样的，像—— [爵士声]
--and, in fact, I sound like this-- (SINGING) Na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na. So I'm onstage at the charity golf tournament, and I'm just Kenny G'ing it up, for 10 minutes, just-- [SINGING OFF KEY]
——而事实上，我的声音是这样的——（演唱）啦，啦，啦，啦……所以我站在慈善高尔夫球赛的舞台上，我只是在演奏肯尼·基，持续了10分钟，只是—— [走音演唱]
--just blowing that horn. And I don't want to fail. I mean, that's a really important point in this story is that these are good people. And I want to succeed for them, but I just can't.
——只是在吹那个号。我不想失败。我的意思是，这个故事中一个非常重要的点是，这些人都是好人。我想为他们成功，但我就是做不到。
And so I think to myself, why don't I cater my material to this specific event? And everyone has been talking about cancer.
所以我想，我为什么不根据这个特定活动定制我的内容呢？每个人都在谈论癌症。
[AUDIENCE EXCLAIMING AND LAUGHING]
[观众惊呼和笑声]
I know. I'm in the future also.
我知道。我也在未来。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
I had that thought on stage for about one second and then batter up. I said to the audience-- true story, I said I went to the doctor, and they told me there was something in my bladder. And whenever they tell you that, it's never anything good-- like, we found something in your bladder, and it's season tickets to the Yankees!
我在台上想了一秒钟，然后轮到击球了。我对观众说——真实故事，我说我去看医生，他们告诉我我的膀胱里有东西。每当他们那样告诉你时，从来不是什么好事——就像，我们在你的膀胱里发现了东西，是洋基队的季票！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That was the response I was hoping for. At that point, I just threw in the towel. I mean, I was just devastated. I thanked the audience and apologized simultaneously, which I've never done. I was like, thank you. Sorry for ruining your event. And I just kind of walked off.
那是我希望得到的反应。在那一刻，我只是认输了。我的意思是，我简直崩溃了。我感谢观众并同时道歉，这我从未做过。我像是，谢谢你们。抱歉毁了你们的活动。然后我就那样走下了台。
And I was so upset. And I walked over to Joe. And I go, Joe, we are leaving now. And that's when Joe said, and I quote, "Mike, I can't. They're just about to start the raffle."
我非常沮丧。我走到乔那边。我像是，乔，我们现在就走。然后乔说，引用他的话，“迈克，我不能。他们正要开始抽奖。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
"And because everybody left, my odds are amazing."
“因为每个人都走了，我的胜算太棒了。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And that is the worst show I have ever done in my entire life. Yeah.
那是我一生中做过的最糟糕的演出。是的。
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
Mike Birbiglia. His most recent Netflix special is called The New One. And he's organized these funny videos to raise money for people who work at comedy clubs, who, of course, are now out of work. John Mulaney, Maria Bamford, Roy Wood Jr., and many other very funny people do these with him. You can find them at tipyourwaitstaff.com.
迈克·比比利亚。他最新的Netflix特别节目叫《The New One》。他组织了这些有趣的视频来为喜剧俱乐部的员工筹款，他们当然现在失业了。约翰·穆兰尼、玛丽亚·班福德、罗伊·伍德二世以及许多其他非常有趣的人和他一起做了这些。你可以在 tipyourwaitstaff.com 上找到它们。
[MUSIC - "I STARTED A JOKE" BY BEE GEES]
[音乐 - 比吉斯乐队演唱的《I Started A Joke》]
(SINGING) I started a joke, which started the whole world crying. But I didn't see that the joke was on me, oh, no.
（演唱）我开了一个玩笑，导致全世界都在哭泣。但我没看出这个玩笑是我开的，哦，不。
Act Four, "Fiascos As A Force for Good." George Clooney, Barbra Streisand, Jennifer Aniston, Vidal Sassoon, Jodie Foster, Jason Momoa, Brad Pitt, Keanu Reeves, Sharon Stone, and John Travolta, also George Burns, Bob Hope, Gene Kelly, Gena Rowlands, also Quentin Tarantino, John Waters, Nora Ephron-- Margy Rochlin has interviewed all these people. She's written big feature stories for all sorts of big magazines and newspapers.
第四幕，“惨败作为向善的力量”。乔治·克鲁尼、芭芭拉·史翠珊、詹妮弗·安妮斯顿、维达·沙宣、朱迪·福斯特、杰森·莫玛、布拉德·皮特、基努·里维斯、莎朗·斯通和约翰·特拉沃尔塔，还有乔治·伯恩斯、鲍勃·霍普、吉恩·凯利、吉娜·罗兰兹，还有昆汀·塔伦蒂诺、约翰·沃特斯、诺拉·艾芙隆——玛吉·罗克林采访过所有这些人。她为各种大型杂志和报纸撰写过大型专题故事。
But the very, very first big feature assignment that she was actually sent out on was by a publication in 1982, The Los Angeles Reader. They sent out a very nervous, very youthful Margy Rochlin to interview Moon Unit Zappa. Remember her? Daughter of Frank Zappa.
但她真正被派出的第一个大型专题任务是1982年的一家出版物，《洛杉矶读者》。他们派出一个非常紧张、非常年轻的玛吉·罗克林去采访月亮单元·扎帕（Moon Unit Zappa）。还记得她吗？弗兰克·扎帕的女儿。
In this little bit that she does on the song, she's using a lot of this language that-- sort of Valspeak that no one had ever heard before. And it was considered really exotic. And so I was from the valley, so I was sent to go talk to her.
在这一小段歌中，她使用了很多这种语言——某种没人听过的“山谷话”（Valspeak）。它被认为真的很异国情调。我来自山谷，所以我被派去和她谈话。
She is one of your people. Speak to her in your secret, private argot.
她是你们中的一员。用你们的秘密私人行话与她对话。
Exactly. And, of course, what is so touching to me is that I totally bought that. You're right. I'm the right person for the job.
确实。而且，对我来说如此动人的是，我完全买账了。你是对的。我是这份工作的最佳人选。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm going to go speak to her in the valley language, and we will bond.
我要去用山谷语言和她对话，我们会建立联系。
[MUSIC - "VALLEY GIRL" BY FRANK AND MOON UNIT ZAPPA]
[音乐 - 弗兰克和月亮单元·扎帕演唱的《Valley Girl》]
(SINGING) Like, oh my god.
（演唱）像，哦，我的上帝。
Valley girl.
山谷女孩。
Like, totally.
像，完全。
Valley girl.
山谷女孩。
Encino is, like, so bitchin'.
恩西诺简直，太棒了（bitchin'）。
Valley girl.
山谷女孩。
So you get there, and you're a bit nervous. And the pressure is on, which is, of course, the setting for a possible triumph or a possible fiasco.
所以你到了那儿，有点紧张。压力很大，这当然是可能取得成功或可能发生惨败的背景。
Right.
没错。
And what happens next?
接下来发生了什么？
Well, what I noticed was that it was a tense situation. I just didn't feel like it was going very well, and the mother was sort of hovering.
嗯，我注意到情况很紧张。我只是觉得进行得不太顺利，而且她母亲在旁边徘徊。
Well, we have a recording of it, because you had a tape recorder rolling during this.
嗯，我们有录音，因为你当时录着音。
Yes.
是的。
What are some other hangouts in The Valley besides the Galleria?
除了画廊（Galleria），山谷还有什么其他的聚会场所？
Bowling alleys with big arcades are very popular.
有大型游戏厅的保龄球馆很受欢迎。
Oh, I'm trying-- at this point, I'm sort of at that rock bottom level that everyone can get at in an interview, where you're just saying, what's your favorite color? And she's trying to help me along.
哦，我正在——在这一点上，我处于那种每个人在采访中都能达到的最低点，你只是在问，你最喜欢的颜色是什么？她正试图帮我一把。
Kirkwood's is gone. It's now the sports center.
柯克伍德（Kirkwood's）已经没了。现在是体育中心。
Oh, it's the same thing?
哦，是一回事吗？
So we're seated in the den. And the mother made me coffee, but I was too nervous to drink it. But I sort of kept staring at it, and she kept staring at it. And I felt like it was pretty important that at some point I better drain that coffee cup.
所以我们坐在书房里。她母亲给我煮了咖啡，但我太紧张了没喝。但我只是盯着它，她也一直盯着它。我觉得在某个时刻我最好喝掉那杯咖啡非常重要。
And so what happened was Moon told me a joke, and I didn't see the joke coming. And right before she told me the joke, I had taken a big swig of the coffee, which was now cold. And when she told me the joke, I burst out laughing, and I started to choke. And so I pressed my lips together, so I didn't spit it out. I didn't want to do a spit take. And the coffee came shooting out my nose.
所以发生了什么事是，月亮给我讲了个笑话，我没预料到。就在她讲笑话前，我喝了一大口咖啡，现在已经凉了。当她讲笑话时，我爆笑出来，开始呛到了。所以我紧闭嘴唇，这样我就没喷出来。我不想来个“喷咖啡”。然后咖啡从我鼻子里喷了出来。
Shooting out your nose?
从鼻子里喷出来？
Shooting right out my nose.
直接从鼻子里喷了出来。
Are you OK? Put your hands up.
你没事吧？把手举起来。
[COUGHING]
[咳嗽声]
I was really embarrassed, but I couldn't breathe. At the same time, I was choking. And I jumped up, and I sort of started running around the room, knocking things over. And I think that they didn't know what was going on, but the mother began chasing me.
我真的很尴尬，但我无法呼吸。同时，我正在呛着。我跳起来，开始在房间里跑来跑去，撞倒东西。我想他们不知道发生了什么，但她母亲开始追我。
She began chasing you?
她开始追你？
She began chasing me because I was sort of running from corner to corner, trying to catch my breath. And she began sort of chasing me. And at a certain point, she got behind me, and she gave me the Heimlich maneuver.
她开始追我，因为我当时在角落之间跑来跑去，试图恢复呼吸。她开始追我。在某个时刻，她到了我身后，对我用了海姆立克急救法。
Wait. Put your arms up. OK?
等等。举起手臂。好吗？
Let's do the Heimlich maneuver. Oh, god.
让我们做海姆立克急救法。哦，天哪。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[相互插入的声音]
Well, I've been in the news business-- I've been a reporter for 20 years, and nobody's ever given me the Heimlich maneuver while I've been on the story.
嗯，我一直在新闻业——我做了20年记者，从来没有人在我做报道时对我用过海姆立克急救法。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, I always say that it's a benchmark. It's a very low benchmark. And I can do any interview. I can get thrown off a set. I can be cursed out by the subject, but I can leave and get in the car, and I can drive home and think, I didn't blow coffee out my nose.
嗯，我总说这是一个标杆。这是一个很低的标杆。我可以做任何采访。我可以在片场被赶走。我可以被采访对象诅咒，但我可以离开，钻进车里，开车回家心想，我没从鼻子里喷出咖啡。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Now, what happened after that?
之后发生了什么？
It was sort of like we'd all been in an earthquake together. And all of the nervousness left the room, and suddenly we were three gals just chatting. And I remember that I sort of hugged them both when I left.
就像我们一起经历了一场地震。所有的紧张感都从房间里消失了，突然我们成了三个正在聊天的小姐妹。我记得我离开时拥抱了她们俩。
Wow.
哇。
They were now my friends.
她们现在是我的朋友了。
It's interesting, because one of our criteria for a fiasco is that all social order, the normal social structure, breaks down. And literally that's what happens here. The normal interview stops, and the social structure of the moment completely changes. The mom gives you the Heimlich maneuver, and then suddenly it stops feeling like an interview.
很有意思，因为我们对于惨败的标准之一是所有的社会秩序，正常的社会结构，都瓦解了。这正是这里发生的。正常的采访停止了，这一刻的社会结构彻底改变了。妈妈给你用了海姆立克急救法，然后突然之间，它感觉不像是一次采访了。
Yeah. And I have to say that it was a very embarrassing experience, and it completely made me feel close to them. It was so interesting. When Moon's father died a while ago, I bumped into her somewhere, and we both burst into tears. I mean, I really felt like a little sister of mine had a loss. And the starting point was--
是的。而且我不得不说这是一次非常尴尬的经历，它彻底让我感觉与她们亲近了。太有意思了。前阵子月亮的父亲去世时，我在某处碰巧遇到了她，我们都热泪盈眶。我的意思是，我真的感觉就像我的一个小妹妹失去了一样。而起点是——
That moment.
那一刻。
Yeah. To me, the thing about it that's useful is that it shows the useful purpose of a fiasco. That is, when social order breaks down, that can be a force not just for chaos, and for entropy, and for evil, but, in fact, that can be a force for good. It can bring people together.
是的。对我来说，关于这件事有用的一点是，它展示了惨败的有用目的。也就是说，当社会秩序瓦解时，这可能不仅是一种导致混乱、熵增和邪恶的力量，事实上，它也可能是一种向善的力量。它能把人们聚在一起。
Right. It was actually this huge success to me. I'd never been sent out under these kind of circumstances before. And I remember we beat the local paper. The Herald Examiner followed us a week later. So we had the first story, and it was sort of considered the definitive one because we had this glossary of terms that I had made her put together.
没错。对我来说它实际上是一次巨大的成功。我以前从未在这种情况下被派出去过。我记得我们赢过了当地报纸。《先驱审查报》一周后跟着我们。所以我们有了第一篇报道，它被认为是权威的，因为我们有这个我让她整理出的词汇表。
Of valley speak terms?
山谷话词汇？
Of valley speak terms. And then it was syndicated.
山谷话词汇。然后它被联合发表了。
And most of the quotable stuff that you ended up using in your story happened after the--
而你最终在报道中使用的那些可引用内容大多发生在——
Happened-- yeah.
发生在——是的。
Happened after squirting the coffee through your nose.
发生在咖啡从你鼻子里喷出之后。
Exactly, exactly. It's a technique I don't suggest anyone trying.
没错，没错。这是一种我不建议任何人尝试的技术。
(SINGING) It's, like, so bitchin' because, like, everybody's, like, super, super nice. It's like, so bitchin'.
（演唱）它，像，太棒了，因为，像，每个人，像，超级、超级好。它就像，太棒了。
For years afterwards, Moon would send me postcards. And on the postcard somewhere would be a picture of a nose, and there would be liquid coming out of it, sort of like my logo.
多年以后，月亮还会给我寄明信片。明信片上某处会有鼻子的图片，液体会从里面流出来，有点像我的标志。
Ready, ready to the max. I'm sure. It's, like, really nauseating. Like, barf out. Gag me with a spoon. Gross. I am sure. Totally.
准备好了，准备到最大程度。我肯定。这真的令人作呕。像，呕吐。用勺子塞住我（gag me）。恶心。我肯定。完全。
Margy Rochlin. She covers television, podcasts, food, and film in Los Angeles.
玛吉·罗克林。她在洛杉矶报道电视、播客、食品和电影。
(SINGING) Don't look at her way. It's how she gets around. You are damaged and shaken, but you're still in control as far as they know.
（演唱）别看她的路。那是她到处走的方式。你受损且颤抖，但据他们所知，你仍然在掌控之中。
Today's program was produced by Nancy Updike and myself, with Paul Tough, Alix Spiegel, and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors for today's program-- Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help for this rerun from Noor Gill, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney. Our website, thisamericanlife.org.
今天的节目由南希·厄普代克和我本人制作，保罗·托夫、阿丽克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德参与。今天节目的特约编辑——杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。本次重播的制作协助来自努尔·吉尔、斯托·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He used to walk into the studio at the end of each and every episode to grimly assess the damage.
《美国生活》由PRX，国际公共广播交流电台分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他过去每期节目的最后都会走进录音室，严峻地评估损失。
Dead squirrel, ruined pillows, need a new couch. The walls are covered with soot. The fire alarms are going off.
死了的松鼠，毁了的枕头，需要新沙发。墙壁覆盖着煤灰。火警响个不停。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》的更多故事。
(SINGING) You are damaged and shaken, but you're still in control as far as they know. What did they, what'd they say, do you know what I mean? Do ya? Do ya? Do ya?
（演唱）你受损且颤抖，但据他们所知，你仍然在掌控之中。他们说了什么，他们说了什么，你知道我的意思吗？你知道吗？你知道吗？你知道吗？
Oh, great honey. Get you into the show. Oh, don't worry, honey. Always knows the showman.
哦，好亲爱的。带你进节目。哦，别担心，亲爱的。总是了解表演者。